I know we're walking into something
that's already a massive success why
can't as an actor make a show and worry
about how it's going to be received all
I can do is do my best possible job in
performing it you know the King has an
air Damon Targaryen
I'm not being mean to choose between my
brother and my daughter guys
congratulations on this I watched the
first episode what can you say about
your characters viserys Targaryen
he's uh you know he's just a great ruler
he's a good man you know a peacetime
King
very boring but uh yeah now he's a man
who very much in in the you know from
the first episode great tragedy strikes
him and uh you know
um I think he's somebody who's like
trying to be a king that pleases
everybody and ultimately that has a very
detrimental effect on him later on yeah
and Damon is the opposite yes in many
ways but yeah that you know they're
weirdly similar and weirdly opposite
like all siblings but yeah in many ways
he's very opposite his reactionary he's
impetuous he's
violent he's um he's seen her attention
seeking there's a Madness to him yeah he
is intention so you can yeah yeah
totally yeah there's nothing worse if
you're an attention seeker if you're
being ignored by you're going but notice
me notice me what's his relationship
like with renera and then the first
episode it seems like there's when when
members of the same family in the show
stare at each other a little too long
the assumptions are made boo how would
you describe what can you tell me about
their relationship especially by the end
of the episode you know again there's a
very close bond between the two of them
um
and one that is uh you know there is
something very unique about their
relationship compared to his
relationship with anyone else I think he
treats her with more respect
than he does the most and so this is
this is this will be your what thorough
show that's had like an incredibly
passionate fandom Doctor Who the crown
and now Game of Thrones show House of
the dragon two questions one I like how
do you keep doing this well finding
yourselves in this in these positions
that I'm sure many actors would want to
be in and then some question like are
you guys all prepared for the level of a
passion that comes with uh that comes
with this show from the fans I don't
mind passion I can deal with passion
that's great it's a good thing I mean
there's it's certainly uh you know so
passionate that you guys we've discussed
in some of the other rooms the fans are
still a little bit divided some are a
bit bitter even about the the previous
series is a finale episode I'm sure you
can't think about that when you're going
to work but once it's in the can like do
you think about stuff like that can't
take it on you know I I then I do hope
people enjoy it but I can how can I
possibly take that off I know we're
walking into something that's already a
massive success so you know that's
that's a given you know that we're
walking into it's not unknown territory
in a way but I can't you can't make a
show I can't as an actor maker show and
worry about how it's going to be
received all I can do is do my best
possible job in performing it you know
and that's the trip
um the other stuff is completely out of
my control I've served viserys as best I
can I have decided to name a new ad I'm
your head
he's a foot Matt what have you learned
about as I said all these shows that
have such passionate fandoms what have
you learned about navigating fandom or
in your time doing all these shows I've
been very fortunate like you know the
Doctor Who Community is a really lovely
Community to be part of people on on the
whole are very encouraging and only
really positive and and um look this
isn't a new and it's a different genre
and a different community and I don't
know but I look we've tried our best to
make a show that is original and
entertaining and
hopefully what you know we'll have done
but we won't please everyone you know of
course is there a moment when you're
shooting the show that is there's like a
surreal feeling because like you know I
know how they're shooting it now and I'm
sure with all the costumes I'm sure it
feels like I'm sure it feels surreal
right when you're in armor for like
eight hours a day it's like what is this
my job what's going on here and it's
like day four of like a scene when
you're having lunch that stuff gets a
bit mad doesn't it yeah some of these
scenes were shot over about four days
and more yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
so yeah you do get that sense of like if
you ever leave this place you got a bit
cuckoo your family has dragons
there are power men should never have
trifled with if either of you had a
dragon in real life what would you name
it Rufio
yeah nice yeah I don't know I'm not very
good at all that kind of stuff yeah fair
enough who knows yeah all right just
take roof here yeah yeah yeah you can
take it for a spin
[Music]